s'il te plaît eh oui
c'est un paradis
te voilà
plus éblouissante que jamais n'diaye
tulle agathe trop mille tonnes
j'ai les moyens de vous aider
financièrement je peux très bien
m'occuper de nom n'en faites pas une
question d'ego
c'était des jumeaux havrais avec un
merveilleux petit garçon s'était jumeaux
que je les ai vus tu mords je le sais tu
veux ça laissait bronn mon bébé
ferrer jerry paraître elle ne va pas
bien on sait qu'elle n'a pas très bien
pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça
comment tout ça
elle n'avait fait aucune crise depuis
trois ans elle avait arrêté son
traitement comment vous pouviez ne pas
savoir oh c'est moi rappelle moi s'il te
plaît
qu'est ce qui se passe ou ce qui s'en
à l'eau
elle a pris les passeports elle a très
bien pu quitter le pays avec mon fils je
vais appeler la paris pour faire quoi au
juste
cette valve vous l'avez vu
ce qu'elle préfère du mal à passer rien
sans connaître les faits on aura aucune
réponse j'ai besoin de savoir comment
c'est arrivé vous êtes en état de choc
vous devez vous ressaisir
des faits où est votre mère et j'ai vu
quelqu'un qui me suivait
c'est plus le moment de jouer mais pas
en train de jouer oui
c'est ça que vous voulez qu'elle soit
interne et pour le restant de ses jours
[Musique]